alors moi j'ai demandé une seule fois
dans ma vie un autographe à quelqu'un
oui ma vie de mes 31 ans et à michel ça
michel parce que parce que j'ai une
relation particulière avec mon
grand-père qui vous regardait tous les
tous les week-ends où vous étiez dans le
salon dans la famille et ses avocats
demandent un autographe pour lui c'est
le seul et ce sera le seul et vous êtes
dans mon coeur dans ma famille
je vis à vis du public sur scène je
parle beaucoup de johnny aussi après
t'être jambes m'a fait beaucoup rire
jaune et un jeune disait est ce que j me
johnny mal mais j'adore limité à lui pas
si mal timide comme laurent lévy ques et
intimité
pourquoi tout le monde évite le chanteur
ait jamais le par leur convoi qui mettra
pas le parlera alors il m'a donné des
cours et sur scène je raconte des
anecdotes avec johnnie to et johnny
minimes appelait la nuit toujours à 4
heures du matin jet lag est rentré tard
et en 98 avant ce premier stade de
france mythique puisque c'étaient deux
mois après la victoire de zidane en
coupe du monde il m'appela 4 heures du
matin à la cti cas soit tu fais mais je
dors territoire un scot a vu apocalypse
la
toile a alors capté pilote d'hélicoptère
pour mon salles de france va arriver en
formation académique au comme dans
apocalypse now et tu vas me larguer sur
la fugue bonne nuit
je me réveillais gym et je fais un
cauchemar
cette photo là c'est un cauchemar appel
j'ai rêvé que j'arrive au dessus du
stade de france je largue et johnny sur
la foule je me rendors c'est un
cauchemar qu un jour il m'a pas lâchée
pendant des mois je suis ravi de
m'attaquer à la salle jani
tudor team temps sont prêtes zelikow j
venir ne peut pas survolé une foule en
hélico sauf le samedi à luanda avec un
tel écho le savez bien le jour j il le
fait ces quatre mois de préparation on
décolle j'ai des copilotes y avait un
pilote plus chevronnés que moi
sauveteurs en montagne qui étaient là et
on va au dessus du stade de france et on
va on va aller donc le déposez y chante
quatre minutes et demie après ça un docu
hallucinant que je monte sur scène et en
arrivant au dessus de la défense il
hurle six mois de boulot ils urnes dans
le calme par axa de suite j'ai le
vertige
baptisé
refusé et je crois que gerber sur la
défense il n'a pas géré sur la d re il
l'a fait ces jeux le monde sur la ola
regardons là on l'a redit il l'a fait et
c'est seulement le lieu est magique il
est mythique c'est le stade des
champions du monde je n'étais que le
modeste artisan de cette arrivée johnny
quelques mois tu tenais vraiment arriver
par la voie des airs maintenant tu peux
plus reculer
[Musique]
dacca
lycées non non non rift chevalier lui
avait dit eric schmid l'avait vu johnny
avait 17 ans sur scène au début ces
bonhommes si je vais réussir un
spectacle tu arrives avec une chanson
canon a décoré mise en scène incroyable
deux heures après tu termines avec une
chanson du répertoire il a chanté
l'hymne à l'amour la santé b cou au bras
et au milieu des merdes il n'a jamais
oublié ça et tout ses débuts saison
réaction a très bien joué il me dit tu
sais je vais arriver dans un point ya un
bras métallique et au bout il ya le
point le meilleur à johnny dedans alors
qu'un jour se passe comment ça se passe
il ya une couille à l'image y a le point
et s'est pas ouvert
c'est combien temps un quart d'heure si
l'on est alors bill et pire les gens ils
se doutaient que j'étais dans le point
et là qu'ils faisaient et johnny qui
dort à poings fermés j'en attends fini
habitudes
et oui c'est qu'ils vivent ni ses
preneurs parce que quand il naît faire
les émissions soit gabriel tu connais
banque belgique ou dans les galas
j'allais le voir des tours devant la
table de maquillage et me disais
toujours comment ça fait on a pas on a
pratiquement tout à fait le même âge et
t'as pas tout à fait la même gueule que
moi qui n'ai pas encore tout à fait
mieux et moi je suis plus du tout jeune
alors j'aime et johnny tu connais ma vie
je bosse je me couche tôt je bois pas je
ne fume pas je vois des médecins
je fais du sport suite très organisé
je ne bois pas d'alcool j'ai la même fin
de vie 40 ans il disait qu'elle vide
qu'on
s'affermit mais toujours comme ça rien
du moment où
il me manque beaucoup j'ai eu des
souvenirs avec lui absolument incroyable